This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the end of the year and time for our annual mini stories episodes. We have three episodes this year, crusting over the new year, because we have so many stories. Since these are always fan favorites, I didn't think you'd mind if we stretched out a bit. If you're new to this, the mini stories are a hodgepodge of fun, quick hit stories that probably came up in our research for another episode, or maybe it's just some cool thing that someone told us about that we found really interesting, but we knew from doing a little bit of research, they didn't warrant a full episode and two months of hard reporting and interviews, but they're great 99PI stories nonetheless. The best part from
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。年关将至，又到了我们一年一度的迷你故事特辑时间。我们今年有三期节目，跨越新年，因为我们有太多的故事。既然这些节目总是深受粉丝喜爱，我想大家不会介意我们多聊一会儿。如果你对这个节目不熟悉，迷你故事就是一些有趣、节奏明快的杂锦故事，它们可能是我们在为其他节目做调研时偶然发现的，也可能是别人告诉我们的一些很酷的事情，我们觉得非常有趣。但通过初步调研，我们知道它们撑不起一整期节目，也不需要两个月艰苦的报道和采访，但它们依然是很棒的 99PI 故事。从我
from my perspective is that we do them as unscripted interviews where I get to chat with the reporters who work on the show. Sometimes I know a little bit about what they're talking about like we pitch them an meeting, but sometimes I know nothing that keep them from me and that's very fun. This week we have stories about movie novelizations, Swiss defensive architecture, central park lamp posts, and the outlanders costumes of the Swedish supergroup ABBA. I mean there's no way you can hear that list and not listen, right? Stay with us. A first is producer Chris Barouba. So I'm here with producer Chris Barouba, hey Chris. Hey Roman, how you doing?
的角度来看，最棒的是我们以非剧本采访的形式来做这些节目，我可以和参与节目的记者们聊天。有时我对他们谈论的内容略知一二，比如我们在会议上讨论过，但有时我一无所知，他们对我也保密，这非常有趣。本周我们准备了关于电影小说化、瑞士防御工事、中央公园路灯以及瑞典超级乐队 ABBA 的《异乡人》服装的故事。我的意思是，你听到这个清单不可能不听吧？请继续收听。首先是制作人克里斯·巴鲁巴。我和制作人克里斯·巴鲁巴在一起，嗨，克里斯。嗨，罗曼，最近怎么样？
I'm doing pretty good Chris Brubay, Hey Chris. Hey Roman, how you doing? I'm doing pretty good. How about you? I'm well, I'm glad we are doing our mini stories chat. It is. It's the most wonderful time of the year, the mini stories. Partly because it is a less horrible chat with you because I miss coming to Oakland and just having some time where we see each other in person and we can have our movie talks. Exactly, exactly.
我挺好的，克里斯·布鲁贝。嗨，克里斯。嗨，罗曼，你最近怎么样？我挺好的。你呢？我很好，很高兴我们能做迷你故事聊天。确实，这是一年中最美好的时光，也就是迷你故事。部分原因是因为和你聊天没那么可怕了，因为我怀念去奥克兰的日子，怀念我们能亲手相聚、聊电影的时光。没错，没错。
We have to make do with movie talks. Exactly, exactly. We have to make do with movie talks on the Slack channel. That's called movie. What is it called? Is it Chip Movie Club? Movie Club. I think it is. Yeah, it doesn't have quite the same effect.
我们只能将就着聊电影。没错，没错。我们只能在 Slack 频道上将就着聊电影。那个频道叫 movie。叫什么来着？是 Chip Movie Club 吗？电影俱乐部。我想是的。是的，效果不太一样。
Well, okay, so I have decided to import our movie talks into many stories. Perfect. So specifically, I want to talk about a quarantine hobby that I have taken up. I've been reading a lot of movie novelizations. So Roman, do you remember movie novelizations? Sure.
好吧，所以，我决定把我们的电影聊天引入迷你故事中。太好了。具体来说，我想聊聊我最近养成的一个隔离爱好。我一直在读很多电影小说。所以，罗曼，你还记得电影小说吗？当然。
You know, the ones I find funniest are ones that are like these action blockbusters that are the novelization of, I don't know, Transformers Dark Side of the Moon or something. Sure. And you think, why would anyone read that thing? Yeah. Speed, the official movie novelization. Exactly. Exactly. It's funny.
你知道，我觉得最搞笑的是那些动作大片的小说化，比如，我不知道，《变形金刚：月黑之时》之类的东西。当然。你会想，为什么会有人读那种东西？对。《生死时速》，官方电影小说。没错。没错。这很有趣。
There's actually this really rich history to movie novelization. So they go back to pretty much the beginning of movies. So as soon as people started making movies, the producers realized, you know what, we could turn a quick book if we make a book that is based on the movie. But they really took off in the 1970s when Blockbuster films started becoming a thing. So you got Indiana Jones and Star Wars and all these movies coming out. And some of those tie-ins were actually best sellers.
电影小说其实有着非常丰富的历史。它们几乎可以追溯到电影的初期。因此，人们一开始拍电影，制片人就意识到，你知道吗，如果我们根据电影出一本书，就能赚一笔快钱。但它们真正腾飞是在 20 世纪 70 年代，当时大片开始兴起。所以你有了《夺宝奇兵》和《星球大战》以及所有这些上映的电影。其中一些衍生小说实际上还成了畅销书。
Like they made the best seller chart. Wow. I guess if you put yourself back in that head space, it makes a lot of sense. Like back in the 70s, you had to go see a movie in a theater or not, there was no home viewing. Like you had to just wait until it came out on TV or you could get the movie novelization if you wanted to relive the movie.
就像它们上了畅销书排行榜一样。哇。我想如果你把自己带入当时的心理状态，这就完全说得通了。就像在 70 年代，你必须去电影院看电影，或者不看，当时没有家庭观影。就像你只能等它在电视上播出，或者如果你想重温电影，就可以买电影小说。
So it's kind of like if you wanted to quote unquote watch the movie at home, you bought a novelization. Exactly. Like this is the one way that you could relive it and revisit those characters and think about the movie again. That actually makes a ton of sense. I like that. Yeah. But that doesn't explain in this moment of streaming every type of video content that's ever existed, why you are reading them right now.
所以这有点像如果你想在家里“看”电影，你就买一本小说。没错。就像这是你重温电影、回味那些角色并再次思考电影的唯一方法。这其实完全说得通。我喜欢这样。对。但这并不能解释在如今流媒体充斥着各种曾经存在过的视频内容的时代，你为什么现在还要读它们。
True. I could watch Star Wars. If I wanted to watch Star Wars, that option is available to me. So I started getting really interested in these because of the generic product episode that we made. So do you remember the generic branding episode? Of course, it was an instant class. Like everyone loved it, especially your Canadian brethren.
确实。我可以看《星球大战》。如果我想看《星球大战》，我可以选择这么做。所以我开始对这些产生浓厚兴趣，是因为我们制作的通用产品那一集。所以你还记得通用品牌那一集吗？当然，这是一部即时经典。每个人都喜欢，尤其是你的加拿大同胞们。
It was the most Canadian episode of Nightingale PI we've had. So you may recall, one of the people we spoke to for that episode was a guy named Terry Bisson, who was the editor of this series of generic books. This was like a footnote in the story, but- Yeah, but it's a very memorable footnote. It totally is. So, just for Fesher Memory, here's Terry talking about the No Frills books that he helped
那是我们做过的最具加拿大风味的 Nightingale PI 节目。所以你可能还记得，我们在那一集里采访的人之一是一个叫特里·比森的家伙，他是这套通用图书系列的编辑。这就像是故事中的一个脚注，但是——是的，但这是一个非常难忘的脚注。确实如此。所以，为了帮你想起，这里是特里谈论他曾参与编辑的“无品牌”图书。
edit. I thought of it as a satire on publishing. If you could have No Frills cornflakes, why couldn't you have a no frills romance? So, I did this interview with Terry and we're talking and he's actually this really fascinating guy. So, he's a really well-regarded sci-fi writer and we were talking about his career and he mentions that for a while he used to write movie novelizations as a way to make some cash. So, he did some pretty big movies actually like Johnny Newmonic, the Kiana Reeves movie. He did Galaxy Quest. He did a Bruce
我把它看作是对出版业的一种讽刺。既然可以有“无品牌”玉米片，为什么不能有“无品牌”言情小说呢？所以，我采访了特里，我们聊着天，他其实是一个非常迷人的人。所以，他是一位备受推崇的科幻作家，我们谈论了他的职业生涯，他提到有一段时间他曾通过写电影小说来赚取一些外快。所以他确实写过一些相当大的电影，比如基努·里夫斯主演的《捍卫机密》。他写了《银河系漫游指南》。他写了一部你可能还记得的布鲁斯·威利斯的科幻电影，叫《第五元素》。当然。
Willis sci-fi movie that you may remember called the fifth element. Of course. And you remember that movie was a bad 95 or something like that when it came out. And it sold really well. I think the reason it sold was because people thought, well, maybe the book will explain what's going on in the movie, because there's a lot of stuff in the movie that didn't make sense. And they thought, maybe I would make sense of it, but I didn't even try. So I'm talking to Terry. We're talking about his career. And I'm saying, wow, it's really
你还记得那部电影上映时大概是 95 年左右的烂片。而且它卖得很好。我想它卖得好的原因是因为人们觉得，也许这本书会解释电影里发生了什么，因为电影里有很多事情都说不通。他们觉得，也许我能把它弄明白，但我连试都没试。所以我跟特里在谈。我们在聊他的职业生涯。我说，哇，能在所有人之前看到这些电影真是太酷了。特里告诉我一件非常让人惊讶的事情。那就是他从来没看过这些电影。好吧，这确实让人惊讶。这怎么可能？好吧，他可能在电影上映后看过，但在写书的时候他没能看到电影。
cool that you got to see these movies before anybody else. And Terry tells me something really surprising. And that is he never saw the movies. Well, that is surprising. How is that possible? Well, he might have seen the movie after it came out, but he didn't get to see the movie while he was writing the book.
这通常是在电影制作过程中或后期制作时完成的。在最后一分钟，他们想，听着，我们花两万块钱，这能为电影做点宣传。因此，由于制作日程的关系，特里说根据他的经验，当你写小说时，它总是基于剧本而不是实际的电影。好吧，我的意思是，你这么一说这就讲得通了，但一想到这些小说化与电影的实际视觉部分完全没有联系，就真的觉得很诡异。
It's usually done while the movie is either still being done or is in post-production. And at the last minute, they thought, look, we'll spend 20 grand and it promotes the movie a little bit. So because of the production schedules, Terry said in his experience, it was always based off the script and not the actual movie when you're doing the novelization. Well, I mean, I guess that makes sense now that you lay it out, but it is truly weird to think about that these novelizations haven't connected to the actual visual part of the movie at all.
对。当他告诉我这个时，我其实有点怀疑。我想，在没有电影的情况下，你怎么能写出一部电影的小说化作品呢？所以特里在我们聊完通用产品后，把他的一位朋友介绍给了我，她叫莉丝·汉，是另一位写过许多此类小说的科幻作家。她几乎证实了特里所说的一切。她写过《十二只猴子》，她写过《X档案》电影，她说，是的，你拿到的只有剧本。我写了六七部小说，除了一例外，我知道我没有看过电影。既然你一直在阅读这些并做了一些这样的研究，对于写小说的人来说，没有看过电影意味着什么？
Right. I was actually like a little bit skeptical when he told me this. I'm like, how do you write a novelization of a movie with no movie? So Terry, after we had our generic stock, he connected me with a friend of his named Liz Hand, who's another sci-fi writer who wrote a number of these novelizations. She pretty much confirmed everything that Terry said. She did 12 monkeys, she did the X-Files movie, and she said, yeah, all you ever get is the script. I did six or seven novelizations and With one exception. I know did not see a film as you've been reading these and doing a little bit of this research What does it mean for the person writing the novelization to have not seen the movie?
所以这意味着小说的许多细节会与电影不同，因为电影是怎样制作的。所以想想看。我的意思是，部分问题在于，在拍电影的过程中，有些东西会从剧本中改变。所以你知道，演员会想出一句新台词，或者某些特效太贵而无法拍摄。特里实际上告诉过我，当他在写《银河系漫游指南》的书时，他们一直在改结局。他们不断重写该死的剧本，他们可能有一些观众小组告诉他们喜欢什么结局之类的事情。我不得不把最后 10 到 15 页重写了三四次。特里所描述的那种情况，也就是他会回去重写以配合
So what it means is that the novelization will have a lot of detail that is different from the movie Because of how movies are made So think about it. I mean part of the issue is that stuff will change from the script while you're making the movie So you know an actor comes up with a new line or some special effects or too expensive to film Terry was telling me actually when he was writing the galaxy quest book, they kept changing the ending. They kept rewriting the damn script, and they probably had these groups that told them what ending they liked and stuff like that. I had to rewrite the last 10, 15 pages of it three or four times. What Terry's describing, which is like he would go back in and rewrite it to match the
电影，那是相当罕见的。这种情况通常不会发生。所以在很多这样的小说化作品中，修改已经完成了，而制片人就是懒得告诉正在写小说的作家。因此，有所有这些电影小说的例子，其中的细节与电影相比是错误的。因此，有所有这些电影小说的例子，其中的细节与电影相比是错误的。所以罗曼，举个例子，我假设你看过《E.T. 外星人》。
movie, that was kind of rare. That often did not happen. So with a lot of these novelizations, changes got made, and the producers just wouldn't bother to tell the writer who's doing the novel. So there's all of these examples of movie novelizations where there are details that are wrong compared to the movie. there's all of these examples of movie novelizations where there are details that are wrong compared to the movie. So Roman, for example, I assume you've seen ET,
当然看过，是的。最受欢迎的电影之一。现在你还记得《E.T.》里有一个场景，埃利奥特那个小男孩正试图引诱 E.T. 出来，他用的是糖果。雷塞花生酱杯巧克力豆，对。对，超级有名。
the extraterrestrial. Sure, I did, yes. One of the most popular movies ever. Now you remember there's a scene in ET where Elliott, the little kid, is trying to lure out ET and he's using candy. With the Reese's Pieces, yeah. Yeah, it's super famous.
所以在小说里，那是 M&M 豆，因为他们当时还没跟雷塞花生酱杯巧克力豆谈妥合作，对，超级有名。所以另一个例子是《帝国反击战》的小说化。在小说里，尤达是蓝色的。如果你必须描述尤达，你首先会说他是个绿色的家伙。
So in the novel, it's M&Ms because they hadn't struck a deal the Reese's Pieces, yeah. Yeah, it's super famous. So in the novel, it's M&Ms, because they hadn't struck a deal with Reese's Pieces yet. So another example is the Empire Strikes Back, the novelization of that. In the novel, Yoda is blue. If you had to describe Yoda, first thing you say is he's a green guy.
就像他是绿巨人名人堂成员一样。如果有一个绿色事物的名人堂，尤达绝对会在第一轮投票中入选。绝对的。绝对的。所以这种情况经常发生。会做出一些小的改动。最终，你知道，这并不真正毁掉阅读这本书的体验。如果它仍然是同一个故事，不过另一个问题是剧本并不是很详细。所以当你读剧本时，有很多空白。剧本基本上有 120 页的材料，
Like he's a Hall of Fame green thing. If there was a Hall of Fame for stuff that is green, Yoda would be in there on the first ballot. Absolutely. Absolutely. So that thing happens quite a bit. There were like small changes that would get made. And ultimately, you know, that doesn't really ruin the experience of reading the book. If it's still the same story, the other problem though is that screenplays aren't very detailed. So when you're reading a screenplay, there's just like a lot of gaps. The screenplay's 120 pages basically of material,
全都是对话加一些场景指令。你需要很多填充内容。在剧本中，它可能会说，角色走进一个房间，你得不到任何其他细节。所以如果你是写小说的人，你必须填补所有这些细节：房间长什么样，角色穿着什么，所有你无法获取的东西。有时剧本也没有
and it's all dialogue with a few set directions. You need a lot of filler. In a screenplay, it might say, the character's walk into a room, and you don't get any other details. So if you're the person writing the novelization, you have to fill in all these details of what the room looks like, what the characters are wearing, all these things you don't have access to. And sometimes the screenplay doesn't
非常重要事情的细节。所以罗曼，我最喜欢的电影之一是《异形》，如你所知，当然，它很棒。它是最好的之一。关于《异形》的剧本，有一点很有趣。他们没有描述异形。那么当他们必须写小说时，他们做了什么呢？所以我找到了关于阿兰·迪恩·福斯特的一篇老文章，他写了小说化作品，他说他去了电影工作室，问：“嘿，我能看看异形吗？”他们说不。哦天哪，那他做了什么？好吧，在小说化作品里有很多段落，你可以看出他显然在尽量避免具体描述它。
have details of very important stuff. So Roman, one of my favorite movies is Alien, as you know, sure, it's great. It's one of the best. Here's something that's funny about the screenplay for Alien. They don't describe the alien. So what did they do when they had to do the novelization? So I found this old article about Alan Dean Foster who wrote the novelization and he says he went to the studio and was like, Hey, can I see the alien? And they said no. Oh my god, what's so what did he do? Well, there's a lot of passages in the novelization where you could see he's clearly trying to avoid getting specific about it.
所以这里有一个。有一种高大且沉重的模糊暗示。这是稍微晚一点的，在无助的身影上方是一个隐约的轮廓，某种人形的东西，但绝对不是人。哦哇，这听起来为了做到不具体，真是在玩文字游戏。其实挺不错的。
So here's one. There was a vague suggestion of something tall and heavy. And this is a bit later on, above the helpless figure was a faint outline, something man-shaped, but definitely not a man. Oh wow, this sounds real verbal gymnastics to not be specific there. That's pretty good actually.
而且《异形》的小说化被视为该流派的经典。它是一本真正的畅销书。但也有一些情况下，作家试图填补这些细节并添加一些东西，可能有点得意忘形了。给我举个例子。所以一个相当臭名昭著的例子是
And that novelization of Alien is seen as a classic of the genre. It was an actual bestseller. But there are some cases where the writer is trying to fill in these details and add things and gets a little carried away maybe. Give me an example of that. So an example of this that's pretty notorious
《大白鲨 4：复仇》，第四部《大白鲨》电影。可能有点得意忘形了。给我举个例子。所以一个相当臭名昭著的例子是《大白鲨 4：复仇》，第四部《大白鲨》电影，作者加入了一整段背景故事，解释为什么《大白鲨》里的鲨鱼一直追着同一个家族不放。解释是一个巫术诅咒。我想在《大白鲨 4》里，鲨鱼一直跟着埃伦·布罗迪，比如一路跟到巴哈马之类的地方。是的，情况确实如此。很明显写小说的人。就像得到了一些灵感。这是一个逻辑跨度太大的飞跃。所以我必须做点什么来解释它。所以古老的诅咒是连接这些点最简单的方法。
is Jaws the Revenge, the fourth Jaws movie. way maybe. Give me an example of that. So an example of this that's pretty notorious is Jaws the Revenge, the fourth Jaws movie, and the writer added this whole backstory about why the shark in Jaws keeps chasing the same family. And the explanation is a voodoo curse. I think in Jaws the Revenge, the shark follows Ellen Brody, like down to the Bahamas or something like that. Yeah, that is what happens. And clearly the person writing the novelization. It was like to some inspiration. This is a leap in logic that's a little too far. So I have to do something to explain it. So ancient curse is the easiest way to connect those dots.
这跟其他任何解释一样合情合理。当你写作时，这种情况就会发生，你知道，当你碰到一本不知道该怎么写的书时，莉丝·汉给了我一个她职业生涯中的例子，她不得不这样做。我不会说，《猫女》的小说化是我最光辉的时刻，但这是一份薪水。她是指哈莉·贝瑞主演的电影《猫女》吗？对。
It makes as much sense as anything else. And this kind of thing would happen when you were writing and you know, you hit a book where you didn't know what to do. And Liz Hand gave me an example from her career where she had to do this. I won't say that, you know, the novelization of Catwoman is my finest moment, but it was a paycheck. Does she mean the Halle Berry movie, Catwoman? Yeah.
所以哈莉·贝瑞的《猫女》，算是一个臭名昭著的票房毒药，我想上周它在烂番茄上仍然只有 9% 的新鲜度。真惨，对。我能为你效劳吗？等等，俄罗斯。不要冰，来杯伏特加，拿根蜡烛。绿色，纯饮。莉丝拿到了这个剧本，她看了看，意识到，哦不，这简直是一团糟。
So the Halle Berry Catwoman, kind of a notorious flop, I think it still has 9% on Rotten Tomatoes last week. Rough, yeah. What can I do for you? Wait, Russia. No ice, hold a vodka, hold a candle. Green, straight up. Liz was given the script for this and she looks at it and she realizes, oh no, like this
我该怎么办？这里细节太少了。我怎么填满一本书？那她是怎么解决这个问题的呢？所以准备好。她解决这个问题的方式简直太惊人了。所以最后我做的是，书里有一个角色，或者说剧本里。
is a mess. What am I going to do? There's very little detail in here. How am I going to fill a book? So then how did she solve this problem? So get ready. The way she solved this problem is kind of amazing. So what I ended up doing, there was a character in the book, in the screenplay rather.
这是一个配角，就像是一个著名的猫类学家，一个自命不凡的人类学家、考古学家，专门研究猫。猫女这个角色会定期去拜访这个女人，请求，你知道，“哦，帮帮我，哦，猫。告诉我该怎么处理我尖尖的小耳朵。”所以我当时想的是，好吧，我知道我能做什么，尽管这完全不合常规，但我不管怎样都要这么做。所以我写了三四个小猫，我编了三四个小猫的寓言或童话。因此，每次猫女这个角色去看这个女人时，情节就停滞不前了，我把这些东西塞进去，基本上它们是填充物，但对我也很有趣。事实上，莉丝写的这些民间故事之一效果太好了，以至于她设法把它发表在几部短篇小说选集里，包括这本关于猫的故事集，里面有一篇斯蒂芬·金的故事，
It was a supporting character who was like a renowned cat ologist, a supposed anthropologist, archeologist who specialized in cats. And the cat woman character would go periodically to visit this woman to ask for, you know, oh, help me, oh be cat. Tell me what to do with my little pointy ears. And so what I thought was like, okay, I know what I can do, even though this is totally
一篇乔治·R·R·马丁的故事，然后还有她原本在《猫女》小说化作品里的短篇小说。太棒了。这真的太有趣了。我的意思是，这太有意思了，因为几个月前，我想我和你对电影小说的想法可能是一样的。
out of line, I'm just going to do it anyway. So I wrote three or four little cat, I made up three or four little cat fables or fairy tails. And so each time the cat woman character would go to see this woman, the action ground to a halt, I dropped these things in, and basically they were filler, but for me they were fun. And actually one of these folk tales that Liz wrote turned out so well that she managed to get it published in a couple of short story anthologies, including this one anthology of stories about cats, where it's a story by Stephen King,
哦，是的，这些都是粗制滥造的东西。这些看起来像是应付差事的平庸之作。但你挖得越深，就越意识到这里面有创造力。它们有点怪异。它们跟电影本身相比有种独特的风格。对我来说，这是一种思考原版电影的非常有趣的方式，它某种程度上加深了作为粉丝的整体体验。我的意思是，这简直太美妙了。
a story by George R.R. Martin, and then also her short story that was originally in the cat woman novelization. That is so good. It's really funny. I mean, it's so interesting because a couple months ago, I probably had the same thoughts that you did about movie novelizations, I think.
我真的很喜欢。就像人们带着创造力在这个巨大的、你知道的，创意机器的边缘地带运作一样。这太酷了。在我们离开之前，我还有一些特别鸣谢要说。我要感谢我的弟弟丹，他是这些小说的超级粉丝。他为这个故事给了我很好的建议。还要感谢贾斯汀·莫里斯，他给我列出了一份很棒的阅读清单，让我能深入了解这方面的内容。
Oh yeah, these are cations. These kind of seem like hack work. But the deeper you dig into them, the more you realize there's creativity here. They're kind of weird. They're kind of their own thing from the movies. And to me, that's a really interesting way to think about the original movie and it kind of deepens the whole experience of being a fan. I mean, it's kind of beautiful.
还要感谢那些非常严肃的科幻作家作者们，他们纵容了我，并且非常慷慨地花时间谈论这些脚注和他们的职业生涯。所以感谢特里·比森，奥克兰自己的特里·比森，非常感谢莉丝·汉，她的新书。那是一部名为《灯具与旗帜之书》的小说。非常感谢。谢谢你，罗曼。今年在 Transmavia 推特上流传的故事之一，关于纽约市中央公园路灯上的四位数代码。一个叫格洛丽亚（Gloria）在 Lucent 508 的人发推文谈到了公园里这种巧妙的寻路形式，我想大概有一百个人把这个发给了我。
I really love it. Like people operating with your creativity and the sort of marginalia of this gigantic, you know, creative apparatus. It's, it's so cool. I have a few special thank yous before we go. I want to thank my brother, Dan, who is a big fan of these novelizations. He gave me some great advice for this story. Also, thank you to Justin Morris, who gave me a great list of things to read to learn more about this.
因此，公园里的每一盏路灯上都有一个四位数的数字。前两位数字代表这座占地 840 英亩的城市公园里，距离路灯最近的横向街道。所以如果前两位数字是 96，那么该路灯与 96 街平行。后两位数字代表两件事。路灯在路的哪一侧，以及它距离边缘的相对距离。如果是偶数，那么它在公园的东侧。所以，e 代表偶数（even），e 代表东侧（east）。让我看看我是怎么记住的。奇数意味着这盏灯在公园的东侧。不对，等一下。偶数代表东侧。奇数意味着这盏灯在公园的东侧。不对，等一下。偶数代表东侧。奇数意味着这盏灯更靠近西侧。
And thank you to the authors who are very serious science fiction writers who indulge me and we're very generous with their time talking about these footnotes and their careers. So thank you to Terry Bissen, Oakland's own Terry Bissen, and thank you very much to Liz Hand, her new book. It's a novel called The Book of Lamps and Banners. Thank you so much. Thank you, Roman. One of the stories that came over the Transmavia Twitter this year is about the four digit codes on the lampposts in Central Park in New York City. A person named Gloria at Lucent 508 tweeted about this clever form of wayfinding in the park, and I think like a hundred people said it to me.
数字越小，它离边缘越近。所以，举个例子，96.05 大致与 96 街平行，而且它离西侧相当近，因为它是一个很小的奇数。但如果一盏路灯的编号是 9642，它比西侧更靠近东侧，但因为它的数字 42 比较大，所以它更偏向公园中间。因此，如果你在中央公园迷路了，找一盏路灯，读一下上面压印的数字，你就会大致知道自己在哪里。当这个代码的解释，你知道，被互联网上的人们发现时，很多人对此很感兴趣，但他们经常想，如果没人知道，这个酷炫的寻路方法有什么用呢？
So each Lamp Post in the park has a four digit number on it. The first two digits represent the closest cross street to the post in the 840 acre city park. So if the first two digits are 96, the post is parallel to 96th street. The second two digits represent two things. Which side the lamp post is on and its relative distance from the edge. If it is an even number, then it's on the east side of the park. So, e, even, e, east. Let's see how I remember that. And an odd number means that that light is's on the east side of the park. So, e even, e east. Let's see how I remember that. And an odd number means that that light is closer to the west side. The
答案是，它其实不是给我们这些公园游客准备的寻路工具。它实际上是为公园员工准备的，他们的工作是更换和维修这些路灯。但既然你知道了，你就可以蒙上眼睛原地转圈，朝一个方向出发，找到一盏灯，就能知道自己在中央公园的什么位置，这其实很酷。接下来是 99PI 的数字总监、《99% 不可见的城市》的合著者库尔特·科尔斯泰德。接下来是 99PI 的数字总监、《99% 不可见的城市》的合著者库尔特·科尔斯泰德。所以如果你对瑞士的历史有所了解，你大概知道它是一个美丽的山地国家，
smaller the number, the closer it is to the edge. So, for example, 96.05 is roughly parallel to 96th Street, and it's pretty close to the west side because it has a small odd number. But if a lamppost is numbered 9642, it's closer to the east side than it is the west side, but because it has that high number of 42, it's more towards the middle of the park. So if you ever get lost in Central Park, find a lamppost, read the embossed number, and you'll know roughly where you are. When the explanation for this code, you know, found found people on the internet a lot of people were intrigued by it, but they often wondered what good is this cool wayfinding method if nobody knows
而且在涉及全球冲突时，它历来保持尽可能的中立。库尔特·科尔斯泰德来这里讲述这种立场是如何塑造瑞士的人造环境的，包括，你知道的，某种显而易见的方式，但也有非常奇怪和狂热的方式。是的。瑞士到处都是防御性的建筑和基础设施。是的，其中一些相当明显。比如，在一些山丘和山脉的顶部，你可以发现一排排参差不齐的混凝土“牙齿”从地里突出来。有些人称它们为三角巧克力地雷。像巧克力那样？
about it. Well the answer is, it's not really wayfinding for us, for patrons of the park. It's really for park employees, whose job it is to replace and repair those lamps. But now that you know, you could spin around with a blindfold on, set off in a direction, find a lamp, and know where you are in Central Park, which is pretty cool. Up next is the digital director of 99PI, and the co-author of the 99% Invisible City, Kurt Colstein. and the co-author of the 99% Invisible City, Kurt Kohlstead. So if you know anything about the history of Switzerland, you probably know that it's a beautiful mountainous country,
那是标志性的东西吗？也就是你说的以巧克力闻名的东西？是那种带尖角的巧克力吗？正是如此。正是因为那种，你知道的，参差不齐的形状。但这些都是为了阻止敌方坦克从山坡上开进瑞士领土而建造的。所以这些就像——字面意思，如果你把其中一块巧克力从包装里拿出来，
and it has famously remained as neutral as possible when it comes to global conflicts. Kurt Kohlstead is here to talk about how that stance has shaped the built environment of Switzerland, including, you know, kind of obvious ways, but also really strange and fervent ways as well. Yes. Switzerland is filled with defensive architecture and infrastructure. And yes, some of it is pretty obvious. Like, on the tops of some hills and mountains, you can find these rows of jagged concrete teeth just sticking up from the ground. And some people call them toblerone mines. Like the chocolate.
它就是一块混凝土，一块大块的混凝土，看起来就像一块三角巧克力，而且确实如此。是的，基本上是这样。所以这是一个，你知道的，某种显眼防御设计的例子。什么是，什么是更隐蔽的设计？好吧，我从让我陷入整个研究泥潭的那个开始说起。几年前，瑞士政府决定从一座旧桥上拆除一些炸药，这成了新闻。等等，所以他们实际上在桥梁本身里面内置了炸药？是的，这也是我的反应，我理解有同样的疑问。
Is that the thing that's another thing that's what you're in his famous for? Is that spiky chocolate? Exactly. And it's because of that, you know, jagged shape. But these are built up to stop incoming tanks from rolling over hill sides into Swiss territory. So these like literally look like if you were to take one of those chocolate bars out of its package,
我当时想，你为什么要给自己的桥梁装上炸药呢？而关于桥梁的问题是一个古老的问题。它有 700 多年的历史。但在冷战期间，他们在桥上绑了 TNT，以便在遭到入侵时可以炸毁关键支撑结构。好吧。所以他们把那些拆除了。这种战术在瑞士已经不复存在了吗？好吧，情况是这样的。出于安全原因，瑞士实际上不会对此发表评论。所以他们有可能已经不再这么做了。但也有可能他们只是换成了新炸药。而这只是方程式的一部分，对吧？
it's a piece of con, a big piece of concrete that just looks just like a toplerum and it's not like that. Yeah, basically, yeah. So that's an example of a, you know, a kind of an obvious defensive design. What's it, what's it more invisible design? Well, I'll start with the one that sent me down this whole rabbit hole. So a few years back, the Swiss government decided to remove some explosives from an old bridge, and that made the news. So, wait, so they actually had explosives built into the bridge itself? Yes, and that was my reaction to, I understand the same question.
所以有些桥梁两侧还有隐蔽在山腰上的火炮，作为备用系统发挥作用，这样他们就可以撤退。然后，如果敌人试图修复桥梁，瑞士人就可以向他们倾泻火力，阻止他们这样做。因此，所有这一切既是阻止敌人过桥的方法，也是为了防止他们在想要过桥时修复桥梁。没错。所以他们有引爆桥梁的炸药，还有对准桥梁的枪，以防敌人想要过桥。没错。所以他们有引爆桥梁的炸药，还有对准枪口以防敌人想要修复被炸毁桥梁的枪。所以他们的武器库里有各种各样的东西。是的，完全如此。保密和冗余
I was like, why would you rig your own bridge with explosives? And the bridging question is an old one. It's 700 plus years old. But during the Cold War, they strapped TNT to this thing so that key supports could be detonated in case of invasion. Okay. So they removed those. Is that tactic no longer a thing in Switzerland? Well, here's the thing. Switzerland won't actually comment on that for security reasons. So it's possible that they're just done with that. But it's also possible they just swapped it out with new explosives. And this is just one part of the equation, right?
是其中的巨大一部分。而桥梁也只是其中的一小部分。例如，在阿尔卑斯山，政府几十年来开凿了数万个掩体和其他设施。他们还在山里布设了炸药以引发山体滑坡，同样，这也是为了阻止或至少减缓潜在入侵者的速度。然后是那些小村庄。你知道我在说哪几个。你在明信片上能看到它们。你能在那种瑞士山间小镇看到它们，那里有风景如画的小屋、一些农场动物和美丽的风景。这些都是防御设计的一部分。并非全部，但确实有这样一整套伪装设计，
So some bridges are also flanked with artillery, which is like hidden in the mountain side. And works as like a backup system, so they can retreat. And then if the enemy tries to repair the bridge, the Swiss can just rain fire down on them and stop them from doing it. And so all of this is a way to keep the enemies, both from crossing the bridge, and then from fixing the bridge in case they want to come back across. Right. So they got explosives to detonate the bridge, and guns pointed down at them in case they want to come back across. Right. So they got explosives to detonate the bridge and guns pointed down at them in case the enemy wants to repair that bridge if it's been detonated. So they have all kinds of things and they're arsenal. Yes, totally. And secrecy and redundancy
比如藏在舒适的假小屋后面那些可爱小窗户后面的高射炮。这里的并置太疯狂了。看看，看看这个湖。看一看。好吧，哦天哪。小屋里好像伸出了一门大炮。这超级奇怪，对吧？就像，是的。
are a huge part of that. And bridges are also just a small part of that. So in the Alps, for example, the government has carved out tens of thousands of bunkers and other installations over the decades. And they've also rigged explosives up at the mountains to trigger land slides, again, a way of stopping or at least slowing down would be invaders. And then there are those little villages. And you know the ones I'm talking about. You see them on postcards. You see me in like these Swiss hill towns with little picturesque cottages and some farm animals
哇，那真的很了不起。那就是瑞士的大炮。它确实是巨大的。真是别具一格。对我来说真正印象深刻的还有这些东西对细节的关注。所以理论上，这些东西只需要在远距离起作用，对吧？
and beautiful views. Those are part of the defensive design. Not all of them, but yes, there's this whole subset of camouflage designs Like anti-aircraft guns that are tucked behind these cute little windows in cozy-looking fake cottages And the juxtaposition is crazy here. Check out check out this lake. Just take take a look Okay, oh my goodness. There's like a big gun coming of the cottage. It is super strange, right? Like, yeah.
它们不是为了近距离伪装而制作的，但尽管如此，它们的绘制非常巧妙。他们甚至在假悬挑下方画了假阴影。你几乎得直接走到它跟前才能看出它们到底是什么，或者至少看出它们到底不是什么。所以听起来这种方法在某种程度上渗透到了他们防御设计的方方面面。就像它对基础设施的建筑产生了影响。但是，你知道，这是一种特别的
Whoa, that is really something. That's a Swiss gun right there. It really is massive. It's something else. And what really is impressive to me too is the attention to detail on these things. So in theory, these only really need to work in a distance, right?
瑞士特色吗？我的意思是，这种东西就是从这里开始的吗？是的，我的意思是瑞士有可以追溯到 1800 年代的掩体，就像大多数国家一样，但他们在 20 世纪 30 年代开始真正担心并认真对待这些事情。我想知道为什么。是的，对吧。一方面，他们拥有这种相对易守难攻的山地景观。但另一方面，他们完全被一些国家包围着，事实证明，这些国家正处于另一次世界大战的边缘。
They're not made to be camouflage up close, but nonetheless, they're really skillfully painted. They even paint like fake shadows under the fake overhangs. You have to almost walk right up to one to see what they really are, or at least see what they're really not. So it sounds like this approach kind of pervades all kinds of things in terms of their defensive design. Like it has effect on the architecture of the infrastructure. But you know, is this a particularly
所以他们的准备工作是有道理的。所以这在两次世界大战之间出现，但你也提到了冷战。所以听起来他们开始了，但在轴心国和同盟国在他们周围混战之后，他们看到了更大的需求。对。这其实证实了他们的猜想，但他们确实需要这种防御。因此，瑞士希望为一切做好准备，并让潜在敌人进行游击战尽可能困难。
Swiss thing? I mean, is this where this kind of thing started? Yeah, I mean the Swiss have bonkers that you know, day back to the 1800s, like most countries, but they got really worried and really serious about this stuff in the 1930s. I wonder why. Yeah, right. On the one hand, they had this relatively defensible mountainous landscape. But on the other hand, they were completely surrounded by countries that as it turned out, were on the brink of another world war.
因此，除其他外，他们甚至建造了足够多的避难所来容纳整个国家的人口，这是史无前例的。没有其他国家做过类似的事情。它甚至成为了一项政策，确保每个公民在需要时都有权使用掩体空间。嗯，这真的很了不起。然后还有所有这些，你知道的，自我毁灭的，你知道的设计，那个把一切都炸毁的大红色按钮。我的意思是，很难想象为什么我要一个能摧毁一切的按钮。紧急销毁系统现已激活。飞船将在倒计时 10 分钟后自爆。
So their preparations made sense. So this kind of cropped up between those world war. So their preparations made sense. So this kind of cromped up between those world wars, but you also mentioned the Cold War. So it sounds like they got started, but then they saw kind of more of a need even after the access and allies powers fought all around them. Right. Thankly confirmed their suspicion, but they really needed this kind of defense. And so Switzerland wanted to be prepared for anything and to make guerrilla war as hard as possible on potential enemies.
什么情况下才会让你决定真正付诸行动呢？我的意思是，那太疯狂了。如果你从一个工程师的角度来想象这一点，对吧？一个肩负此任务的瑞士工程师。所以他们在建造一座桥，他们建造它是为了让它站立并作为桥梁运作，但他们同时也在建造它以便炸毁或发挥其他功能，对吧？比如变成掩体什么的。我实际上读过这样一个掩体，例如，它实际上只是一个用作铁路隧道的铁路隧道，但里面塞满了物资。他们的想法是，在紧急情况下，他们可以在里面容纳 2,000 人，然后炸毁并使两个主要入口塌陷。所以它就像是一个白天的铁路隧道。然后如果灾难
So among other things, they even built enough shelters to literally house the entire country's population, which it's unprecedented. No other nation has done anything like this. And it even became a matter of policy to make sure every citizen had the right to access bunker space if they needed it. Well, that's really something. And then there's all this, you know, self-destructive, you know, design, the big red button that blows everything up. I mean, it's hard to imagine why I have a button that destroys everything. The emergency destruct system is now activated. The ship will detonate in T-minus 10 minutes.
降临，它就可以变成雕刻在山里巨大无比的掩体。世界在前进。冷战在某些方面演变了。这还是个事吗？他们还在造这样的东西吗？这是瑞士人在建造东西时带有这种防御结构的思维方式的一部分吗？我的意思是，部分是这样的。所以他们现在有了更多公开的结构、设施、基地和类似的东西，但很多这样的东西仍然是机密的。所以很难确切说有多少，但你可以从他们开始出售其中一些地方中看出这种转变。所以，你知道，有些掩体被人们改造成了房子，
What circumstance makes you decide to really go through with that? I mean, that's the crazy thing to be in. And if you could imagine this from the point of view of an engineer, right? A Swiss engineer who is tasked with doing this. So they're building a bridge, they're building it to stand up and work as a bridge, but they're simultaneously building it to blow up or to serve another function, right? Like to be turned into a bunker or whatever. And I actually read about this one bunker, for example, that is really just a railway tunnel that's used as a railway tunnel, but they've packed it with supplies. And the idea is that in an emergency, they can house 20,000 people in there and they'd blow up and cave in the two main entrances. So it's like a rail tunnel by day. And then if disaster
而且这些曾经容纳过火炮的假房子现在在某些情况下也变成了容纳人们的真房子。像那样。我们在关于多伦多的书中写过类似的东西，那些被伪装成房子的变电站，然后技术发展到了不再需要这种转换器的程度，
strikes, it can be this huge, huge bunker that's carved into a mountain. The world has moved on. The Cold War has evolved in certain ways. Is this still a thing? Are they still making things like this? Is this part of the Swiss mentality when it comes to building things to have this kind of defensive structures? I mean, it is in part. So they now have more publicly known structures and installations and bases and things, but a lot of this stuff is still classified. And so it's hard to tell exactly how much, but you can see this shift in that they've started to sell off some of these places. So, you know, there's some bunkers that people have turned into houses,
因此那些房子变成了真正的房子。是的，完全如此。这是一个非常强烈的平行对照。这也是为什么我说我想在书中讨论这个，而那一节变得有点长的原因之一。是的。我脑子里闪过一个想法，所以我觉得有点重复。假装成一个东西足够久。也许你最终会真正成为那个东西。
and also these fake homes that once housed artillery are now in some cases becoming real homes, that house people. Like that. That's something that we wrote about in the book with Toronto, the electric substations that were Cameloges' houses and then the technology evolved past the point of needing these kind of converters
木偶奇遇记变成了一个真正的男孩。绝对的。谢谢你，库尔特。非常感谢。我们还有一个关于奇怪税法的迷你故事，这个税法让 ABBA 穿成他们那种样子。也许吧。广告之后见。接下来是制作人维维安·勒。嗨，维维。
and therefore those houses became actual houses. Yeah, exactly. It's a really strong parallel. It's one of the reasons I was like, I thought about talking about this in the book and that section was getting a little bit long. Yeah. I came up a flash so I felt a little redone it. Pretend to be a thing long enough. Maybe you'll go off to be that thing.
嗨，罗曼。那么你今年给我们准备了什么？所以我今年迷你故事想做的是聊聊 ABBA 乐队，因为这是一个非常漫长、非常艰难的一年，而 ABBA 给带来了我很多快乐。你有什么关于 ABBA 的具体内容吗？你只是想多聊一会儿 ABBA 吗？我其实很想聊聊 ABBA 和妈妈咪呀电影宇宙，以及它有多棒，但我确实有一些我想具体聊聊的事情，那就是 ABBA 的服装。因为我认为这已经被记录得很清楚了，
Milkio becomes a real boy. Exactly. Thank you, Kurt. Thanks so much. We have one more mini story about the strange tax law that made Abba dress the way they do. Maybe. After this. Up next is producer Vivian Le. Hey Viv.
他们在表演时总是穿着这些离谱的舞台服装。是的，他们可不是以低调闻名的。不。所以我想我只是要带你快速浏览一下 ABBA 的一些最佳造型，这样我们就能达成共识。所以我发了一张照片，这真是绝了。这真是个造型。
Hey Roman. So what do you have for us this year? So what I wanted to do for my mini story this year is talk about the band AbBA because it's been a very long, very difficult year and ABBA brings me a lot of joy. Did you have anything specific about ABBA? Did you just want to chat about ABBA for an extended minute? I would actually love to chat about ABBA and the momomious cinematic universe and how much it rules, but I actually do have something specifically that I wanted to talk about, and that's ABba's outfits. Because I think it's pretty well documented
哦天哪。是的，确实如此。是的，所以左边的弗里达（Frida），她穿着连体蛇皮衣。你旁边是本尼（Benny），他穿着一件蓝色西装外套，翻领是用巨大的鸵鸟羽毛做的。但我最喜欢的是最右边的比约恩（Bjorn），他穿着一套从头到脚的紧身蓝色连体衣，还带着斗篷。我的意思是，他们看起来有点像职业摔角手，或者有点像马戏团演员，或者可能是马戏团表演的职业摔角手。在这张照片里，比约恩看起来简直就像要被大炮发射出去一样。没错。
that they consistently dressed in these outrageous stage costumes we're in performing. Yeah, they were not known for their subtlety. No. So I guess I'm just gonna give you a quick tour of some of Abba's best looks so that we could be on the same page. So I dropped in a photo, which is a lot. It's a look.
哦，太棒了。我知道我太喜欢了。但是，我想专门谈谈 ABBA 的时尚选择的原因是，我读到过一个非常奇怪的冷知识，你知道，如果这是真的，这绝对是我完美的迷你故事。ABBA 的服装之所以那么出挑、那么疯狂，是因为根据当时的瑞典税法，如果你是一个表演者，而你的服装不适合日常穿着，它们就可以用来抵税。
Oh my god. Yeah, indeed. Yeah, so Frida, who's on the left, she's wearing snake skin jumpsuit. You've got Benny next to her who's wearing like this blue blazer and his lapels are made out of a giant like ostrich plume. But my favorite is Bjorn, who's on the very right, he's wearing a head-to-toe jumpsuit, blue skin tight with a cape. I mean, they kind of look like professional wrestlers or kind of like circus performers or maybe circus performing professional wrestlers. Like Bjorn literally looks like he's about to be shot out of a cannon in this picture. That's right.
太搞笑了。所以重点是，如果你是一个音乐家，你的舞台服装对于去参加生日派对或宜家之类的日常穿着来说实在太不切实际了，你实际上可以把它们作为服装报销。它们是职业服装。是的，完全如此。这已经被许多不同的网站报道过，但据报道，这种特殊的税法鼓励了 ABBA 的服装设计师把他们的舞台服装设计得，你知道的，尽可能浮夸。
Oh, it's so good. I know I love it so much. But like, the reason why I want to talk about Abba's fashion choices in particular is because I had read this really weird piece of trivia that, you know, if it's true, makes this the perfect mini story for me. The reason why Abba's outfits were like so out there and so wild was because according to Swedish tax law at the time, if you're a performer and your costumes were not suitable for everyday wear, they were tax deductible.
哦，真是太棒了。我知道我非常喜欢它。但是，我想专门谈谈阿巴乐队（Abba）的时尚选择，原因是我读到了一条非常奇怪的趣闻，如果这是真的，这对我来说简直是一个完美的小故事。阿巴乐队的服装之所以如此出格和疯狂，是因为根据当时瑞典的税法，如果你是一名表演者，并且你的服装不适合日常穿着，那么这些服装是可以税前扣除的。
That's so funny. So the point is, if you're a musician and your stage clothes are just too impractical for everyday wear to go to a birthday party or an Ikea or something, you could actually write them off as costumes. They were professional wear. Yes, exactly. This had been picked up by a bunch of different websites, but it was reported that this particular tax law encouraged Abba's costume designer to make their stage outfits, you know, as flamboyant
太搞笑了。所以关键是，如果你是一个音乐家，你的舞台服装对于日常穿着去参加生日派对、宜家或者其他地方来说太不切实际了，你实际上可以把它们当作服装报销。它们是职业装。是的，完全正确。许多不同的网站都报道过这件事，据报道，正是这项特定的税法鼓励了阿巴乐队的服装设计师将他们的舞台服装设计得如此华丽
and essentially as unwearable as possible. Yeah. I mean, this actually kind of reminds me of the fact that bricks were taxed differently in England at different times and so you can sort of date how old a building is by the size of its bricks. So there's all kinds of things in the design world that are due to, you due to mundane tax considerations and not because of some grand design idea, but it does make me think, you know, in the case of how flamboyant these costumes are and because it's ABBA and because it's the internet. You know, just like how much this is true versus how much this is just ABBA clickbait. Yeah, exactly, because this is still disco music that they are dressing for.
基本上是尽可能做到无法日常穿着。是的。我的意思是，这其实让我想起一个事实：在英国，砖块在不同时期被征收不同的税，所以你差不多可以通过砖块的大小来判断一座建筑有多老。因此，设计界有各种各样的东西都是由于世俗的税收考量，而不是出于什么宏大的设计理念，但它确实让我觉得，你知道的，就这些服装有多么华丽而言，而且因为这是ABBA，又因为这是互联网。你知道的，这其中有多少是真的，又有多少只是ABBA的点击诱饵。对，完全如此，因为这仍然是他们用来穿着跳迪斯科的音乐。
Exactly. And it got kind of hung up on this. So I ended up calling somebody to find out. Yes, Vivian. I'm with you. Hi, you know, it was me. Is now still a good time to talk? Yes, of course.
没错。然后我就在这个问题上纠缠了很久。所以我最后打电话给某人想弄个明白。是的，薇薇安。我跟你在一起。嗨，你知道的，是我。现在还是说话的好时机吗？是的，当然。
And nothing can take me away from you onto the death door spot. That's a charmer there. Seriously. So who is this? So this is Oversensrum. My name is Oversensström. I am among other things, the designer of the world famous Abogur Up from Sweden. Wow, so you went straight to the horse's mouth. This is the sword. Yes, exactly. And I really wanted to talk to Uva,
没有什么能把我从你身边带走，直到死亡降临。真是个迷人的家伙。说真的。所以这是谁？这是奥弗·森斯特伦。我的名字叫奥弗·森斯特伦。除其他身份外，我还是来自瑞典的世界著名ABBA服装设计师。哇，所以你直接去问了当事人。这就是消息源。是的，完全正确。我真的很想和乌韦谈谈，
not just because he knows the answer to this tax question, but also because he might literally have the most fascinating career on the planet. I'm also Professor of Science, teaching young people to become zookeepers and working with wildlife and endangered species. I'm actually also working as a safari guide in Kenya. I've been doing that for 25 years. What? So he's a zoologist who leads safari tours in Kenya and also designed all the costumes for Apple. Yes, and he also arranges flowers, and he owns a restaurant,
不仅因为他知道这个税务问题的答案，还因为他可能拥有地球上最引人入胜的职业。我还是科学教授，教年轻人成为动物园管理员，并从事野生动物和濒危物种的工作。其实我还在肯尼亚担任野生动物园导游。我已经做了25年了。什么？所以他是一个在肯尼亚带野生动物园旅游的动物学家，同时还为ABBA设计了所有的服装。是的，他还安排插花，他拥有一家餐厅，
but probably the thing that he's really known for now is his work with endangered animals. He's actually one of those television animal specialists who will bring like tarantulas and tortoises on the talk shows, so he's basically like the jackhanna of Sweden. Totally. I know exactly what you mean. He actually started out his career wanting to work with endangered animals and just kind of fell into costume design. So how does one do that? How does one go from working with animals to
但可能让他现在真正广为人知的是他与濒危动物合作的工作。他实际上是那种会在脱口秀节目中带狼蛛和乌龟上节目的电视动物专家，所以他基本上就像瑞典的杰克·汉纳。完全明白。我完全知道你的意思。他其实一开始的职业生涯是想从事濒危动物工作，然后阴差阳错地走上了服装设计之路。那么一个人是怎么做到这一点的呢？一个人是如何从与动物工作过渡到
Abba? Well, that's also kind of a wonky story. So according to Uva, he was at university studying like zoology and botany and marine biology. You see, studying at the university was quite expensive. So I had to earn some money. And you see, believe it or not, but during a period of my young life, I was studying the art of flamenco. Wait, flamenco dancing. That was it? Wait, flamenco dancing. Is that what he says? Yes, flamenco dancing. Okay, so let's back up for people who just told us. He's a zoologist who leads Safari tours in Africa. He designs costumes for Abba and is also, was a professional flamenco dancer.
ABBA的？嗯，这也是一个有点古怪的故事。据乌韦说，他在大学时主修动物学、植物学和海洋生物学。你看，在大学学习相当昂贵。所以我必须赚些钱。你看，信不信由你，在我年轻的一段时期里，我一直在学习弗拉门戈艺术。等等，弗拉门戈舞蹈。就是这样？等等，弗拉门戈舞蹈。他是这么说的吗？是的，弗拉门戈舞蹈。好的，让我们为刚告诉我们的人倒带一下。他是一位在非洲带领野生动物园旅行的动物学家。他为ABBA设计服装，而且过去、曾经是一名职业弗拉门戈舞者。
Yes, he's literally the most fascinating person on the planet. So Uva told me that he basically started sowing because he and his fiancee, you know, at the time, they had this background in flamenco dancing. And Uva figured that they could earn some extra money by performing at Flamenco clubs. But there was this one problem, which was that his fiance said
是的，他简直是地球上最迷人的人。所以乌韦告诉我，他基本上开始缝纫是因为他和当时的未婚妻在弗拉门戈舞蹈方面有一些背景。乌韦觉得他们可以通过在弗拉门戈俱乐部表演来赚取一些额外的钱。但有一个问题，那就是他的未婚妻说
that she didn't have any flamenco dresses to perform in. And I said, that's not a problem darling. I will make one for you. And of course, you laugh. And she said, but you can't make flamenco dresses. Oh, where come on? It's quite complicated. And you see, you shouldn't say no to a person like me.
她没有任何弗拉门戈舞裙可以用于表演。我说，亲爱的，这不是问题。我会为你做一件的。当然，你笑了。她说，但你不会做弗拉门戈舞裙。哦，拜托！这相当复杂。你看，你不应该对像我这样的人说不。
So he ended up taking his mother's old dresses and then teaching himself how to make flamenco dresses. And he just ended up being being very naturally good at it. So the dresses that he was making for his fiance caught the eye of a local theater group in the area. So he started designing for them. And then he started working with local musical artists making costumes for musical performers.
所以他最后拿了他妈妈的旧裙子，然后自学如何制作弗拉门戈舞裙。他最终在这方面非常有天赋。所以他为未婚妻制作的裙子引起了当地一个剧团的注意。因此他开始为他们设计服装。然后他开始与当地的音乐艺术家合作，为音乐表演者制作服装。
And that's how he ended up meeting Frida from ABBA. So she took her friends, three of them, and herself of course, to my studio. And I said, well, tell me, tell me, friends. Frida från Abba. Såg honom för att honom har förkostade till Mastudio. Jag kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att honom kunde jag säga att was, remember them. Remember, nothing is too wild. I guarantee he did regret that many times. So the first outfit that he ended up designing for Abba as a group was for this video called Ring Ring. Those are actually the costumes from the picture that I showed you above where, you know, free does in the snake skin jumpsuit and Bjorns in that blue body suit with the cape. If you look at it you can see Bjorn he looks like something between a
这就是他如何结识来自ABBA的弗里达的。所以她带着她的三个朋友，当然还有她自己，来到了我的工作室。我说，好吧，告诉我，告诉我，朋友们。弗里达来自ABBA。她带朋友来到我的工作室。我当时对她说，记住他们。记住，没有什么太疯狂的。我保证他为此后悔了很多次。所以他最终为ABBA作为一个组合设计的第一个造型是为一个名为《Ring Ring》的视频拍摄的。这些实际上就是我上面向你展示的图片中的服装，你知道的，弗里达穿着蛇皮连体裤，比约恩穿着那件带披风的蓝色紧身衣。如果你仔细看，你可以看到比约恩，他看起来介于
circus artist a drag show and Superman. He has a cape he has this leotard you know with big with big sequences, enormous platform shoes. Well, it looks really crazy. Because you see, I was so fascinated by circus because I had some friends working with circus and look at these outfits and costume and you got a small circus company. Really, it was the first time that a pop group should be dressed with blooms and with sequences and leotals and everything. And that was the beginning. So what do you say in there? Is the reason why Avav, look like they were straight out of the circus
马戏团艺术家、变装秀和超人之间。他披着斗篷，穿着这种有大亮片的紧身连衣裤，巨大的松糕鞋。嗯，看起来真的很疯狂。因为你看，我对马戏团非常着迷，因为我有一些朋友在马戏团工作，看看这些服装和行头，你就有了一个小型马戏团公司。真的，这是流行乐队第一次穿着蓬蓬裙、亮片和紧身衣等各种服装出现。这就是开端。所以你在那里说了什么？ABBA看起来像是直接从马戏团走出来的原因
in that music video is because Uva was literally inspired by the circus. Yes, exactly. Ova was literally inspired by the circus. Yes, exactly. It's a straight line. Yes. Well, so I guess the big question is, is did that tax deduction incentive encourage Ova to make their outfits even more absurd? That's a very fun story.
在那支音乐录影带中，是因为乌韦字面意义上受到了马戏团的启发。是的，完全正确。乌韦字面意义上受到了马戏团的启发。是的，完全正确。这是一条直线。是的。好吧，所以我想最大的问题是，税收减免的激励是否促使乌韦把他们的服装设计得更加荒谬？这是一个非常有趣的故事。
Well, it is actually partly, partly true, but not concerning Abba. But can you imagine Abba wearing these outfits when they go shopping, singing honey, honey, you want to buy some honey, yes, and I won't sell that. So he said that while he did purposefully make costumes more in practical for tax reasons for other musicians, that was never his goal when he was designing for ABBA. I had some artists who came to me because I made costumes for most of Swedish artists, really most of them, and some of them came, can you please write me paper to the tax authorities
嗯，这其实部分、部分是真的，但与ABBA无关。但是你能想象ABBA穿着这些服装去购物，唱着“蜂蜜，蜂蜜，你想买点蜂蜜吗，是的，我不会卖那个”吗？所以他说，虽然他确实为了税收原因故意让其他音乐家的服装变得更加不切实际，但这在他为ABBA设计时从来都不是他的目标。有些艺术家来找我，因为我为大多数瑞典艺术家制作服装，真的绝大多数，其中一些人来找我，你能帮我给税务部门写张纸条吗
so you can convince them that this outfit is not suitable for wearing at a funeral or at a dinner sitting or whatever. So that happened three or four times. So actually it's partly true because there was a law and it's still a law is written. But I can tell you it was never any part of any of the costumes that are designed and produced for the Abergrook never ever. So now you've got a complete answer. So in the end were Aber's costumes tax deductible? I mean, probably because they were clearly not...
这样你就可以说服他们这套衣服不适合在葬礼、晚宴或其他场合穿着。所以这种情况发生了三四次。所以实际上这部分是真的，因为曾有一条法律，而且现在仍然是一条明文法律。但我可以告诉你，这绝对不是为ABBA集团设计和制作的任何服装的一部分，从来都不是。所以现在你得到了一个完整的答案。所以最后ABBA的服装可以抵税吗？我的意思是，可能可以，因为它们明显不……
Yeah. Yeah, like seriously, like why not write them off? They're not suitable for everyday use. But that wasn't a factor in how OVA designed for the group. Like I know that the tax deduction story, you know, makes for a good story, but I kind of like his answer better. I mean, you know, he didn't create these bonkers outfits for Abba because he needed to. It's just because he wanted to, you know? Yeah, exactly. Like OVA was telling me that his inspiration came from everything, from like the animals that he worked with, to Swedish flowers, to his friends at the circus.
对。对，就像说真的，为什么不把它们报销呢？它们不适合日常穿着。但这并不是乌韦为该组合设计时的考量因素。我知道关于税收减免的故事听起来很棒，但我其实更喜欢他的回答。我的意思是，你知道的，他并不是因为需要才为ABBA创造了这些疯狂的服装。只是因为他想这么做，你知道的？是的，完全正确。就像乌韦告诉我的那样，他的灵感来自于一切，从他一起工作的动物到瑞典的花朵，再到他在马戏团的朋友。
So what he created was really a reflection of his eclectic background. And he really does have an eclectic background. We're a fascinating man. Oh, Vivian. Well, that was great. Well, thank you for solving that mystery that I didn't know. I actually needed soft. It was my pleasure. I did want to give a quick thank you to the Aba Museum in Stockholm
所以他创造的东西确实是他折中背景的反映。而且他确实拥有一个折中的背景。我们真是一个迷人的男人。哦，薇薇安。嗯，太棒了。好吧，谢谢你解开了这个我甚至不知道我需要被解开的谜团。这是我的荣幸。我确实想对斯德哥尔摩的ABBA博物馆表示快速的感谢
for connecting me with OVA. Oh, that's great. Well, and thanks to OVA. That's probably the most interesting man we've had on our show. He's the most fascinating person I've ever talked to in my life. Thank you, OVA. I love it. Thanks. Thank you. I love it. Thanks. Thank you. If we don't hear from each other, a very, very Merry Christmas, and a Happy New Year. Or as we say within the family, Happy New Year. Happy New Year. As we say. Bye bye, Vivian! We're going to be hearing more mini stories from the rest of the 99 PI crew as the first two episodes of 2021.
感谢他们让我与乌韦取得了联系。哦，那太棒了。好的，也谢谢乌韦。那可能是我们节目中有史以来最有趣的男人。他是我一生中谈过话的最迷人的人。谢谢你，乌韦。我很喜欢。谢谢。谢谢。我很喜欢。谢谢。谢谢。如果我们没有听到彼此的消息，祝大家圣诞快乐，新年快乐。或者正如我们在家族中所说的那样，新年快乐。新年快乐。正如我们所说。再见，薇薇安！随着2021年前两集的播出，我们将听到99 PI团队其他成员带来的更多迷你故事。
Happy New Year. The rest of the 99 PI crew is the first two episodes of 2021. Happy New Year. As of the end of 2020, 99% invisible is Katie Mangle, Kurt Colesde, Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Rihau, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Sophia Klatsker, Chris Barube, Abby Medon, Christopher Johnson, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Discover, listen, and support them all at radiotopia.fm.
新年快乐。99 PI团队的其余成员是2021年的前两集。新年快乐。截至2020年底，99% Invisible的成员包括Katie Mangle、Kurt Colesde、Delaney Hall、Emmett Fitzgerald、Sean Rihau、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Le、Sophia Klatsker、Chris Barube、Abby Medon、Christopher Johnson以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上发现、收听并支持他们所有人。
You can find us and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork, or on Instagram, and read it too. I bet you can still buy a last minute copy of the 99% invisible city just in time for Christmas if you act right now. Get it at your local bookstore or by going to 99pi.org slash book. I know that your daily habits have changed a lot this year and for the people who have stayed with us listening from week to week, I thank you.
你可以在Facebook上找到我们并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，或在节目@99PI Ork上@我们，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到我们。我敢打赌，如果你现在采取行动，你仍然可以买到一本最后一分钟的《99% Invisible City》来赶上圣诞节。在你的当地书店购买，或访问 99pi.org/book。我知道你日常的习惯今年发生了很多变化，对于那些每周都坚持陪伴我们收听的听众，我谢谢你们。
I am grateful and I do hope you keep coming back. There's so much more good stuff in 2021. I cannot wait. Keep in touch at nyanp.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我很感激，也希望你们能继续回来。2021年还有更多精彩内容。我等不及了。请通过 nyanp.org 与我们保持联系。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。